we have a voicemail number that number
is 219 to david p
here's a voicemail i received with a
very practical question about if it came
time to leave the country would you
still be able to leave the country it's
a very good question
hi david i just heard you say on the
stream that if the united states becomes
a full-blown dictatorship by 2024
yeah you will be leaving the country so
i've been thinking about this a lot
myself and
is it too late
if you wait until it's a full-blown
dictatorship will you even be able to
leave this country if you're that
concerned about it happening should you
be making plans to leave before it goes
full-blown dictatorship yeah this is a
fair question which is like if things
completely changed overnight in the u.s
and all of a sudden no one was allowed
to leave the plan of saying i will stay
if and until it gets really bad
doesn't work because if it got so bad
you wouldn't be allowed to leave i don't
you know when we talk about the canadian
political scientists who said the us
could be a dictatorship by 2030 or
whatever else the case may be
i believe that will it would be a
continued slow slide in that direction
and i am counting on the the belief
that i would have time to get out if
such a time came now would i if it's so
slow that the frog doesn't realize it's
getting burned right would i know when
it's time to leave these are all fair
questions but i don't think it would be
like an overnight no more flights out i
just don't think that that's the case uh
but maybe some people in the audience
have a different perspective on the
bonus show today
we will talk about the 5g airline
kerfuffle that's going on we'll explain
it and talk about what's going on um new
mexico has an interesting approach to
all of the teachers out sick with
omicron they're bringing in the national
guard to teach very interesting
and a louisiana senate candidate has
gone viral for smoking cannabis in a
campaign ad we will tell you
who it is and why he did it and what the
effect is going to be on the campaign
all of those stories and more on today's
bonus show sign up at
joinpackman.com get instant access and i
will see you then